aj brown as pete points out it is a low
bar uh aj brown the
titans receiver continuing to make an
aggressive play seriously to get julio
jones in tennessee again aj brown not
the gm not the coach not the owner that
isn't stopping him from doing everything
in his power to get julio jones
attention here's
the latest pitch from the titans
receiver to get another titans receiver
in tennessee
okay i'm going to show you on some
things right here listen to me closely
you have 10 here mr finger roll himself
every time air heal listen he does what
he needs to be done like he's a leader
he's a great passer
he's it anyway next
him behind me superhuman we don't even
have to discuss him he speaks for
himself look how mean he look in the
picture like okay then me i'm up and
coming pro ball year two not a big deal
kind of a big deal but not really okay
scratch that anyway whatever
you
the goat of our arrow the of our
receivers help me help you
come home julio come home
hey look well done i think that i think
that julio's already sold on atlanta i i
think that
aj brown needs to direct his powers of
persuasion to folks in the organization
yeah right
right because i'm sold i'm i'm i i i
would buy anything from aj brown well
done great pitch
uh and uh entertaining so
i i like it i like it and and i won't be
surprised if come next wednesday
julio jones ends up playing for the
titans chris i i don't want i won't
either you know you you know i i said it
earlier in the week that i had heard
that that was certainly a team on his
list it is really well done by aj brown
there's a need for that team and i don't
know the more that this goes by and the
fact that he kind of keeps like
beating this the subject a little bit
makes me believe that
maybe you know julio he's found out from
julio that this guy this team's on his
list and kind of wants to go here and
maybe aj brown's doing it to kind of put
a little public pressure on the
situation and get people behind it and
tennessee to maybe put john robinson and
vrabel under some pressure to get it
done i don't know and here's the other
side of it hey look yeah here's the
other side of it too
uh if mike vrabel had any issues with
what aj brown was doing
mike verable the coach of the titans
would have no hesitation
when it comes to telling him stop doing
that that's the point you're exactly
right if the first one was yes
uncomfortable for the organization
you're right somebody would have reached
out and we wouldn't have saw a second
one so yeah they seem to be okay with it
and like we talked about there's a a
real scheme fit a need for that other
guy
you know josh reynolds you see there
they got him this past offseason from
the rams and free agency he's gonna be
great in a lot of ways but he's a number
three receiver he's not your guy at
least in my opinion that you want to be
your number two uh not with like this
super bowl caliber team and the way they
play with running the ball and all those
type of things either so that's where it
really makes a lot of sense and i'm with
you i wouldn't be surprised if we saw
that happen next week
and at tight end as chris berman would
probably not say anthony who the firster
is that guy
so they could use all sorry i sorry
anthony i i didn't mean anything by it i
just couldn't resist it probably not the
first time he's heard it not exactly the
high end on the comedic scale it's very
very
very low hanging fruit
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports